[Musica]
devo subito avvisarvi di
stare un po fuori dagli schemi perché io
nella vita ho fatto comizi e relazioni
discorsi eccetera ma adesso la vecchiaia
delle volte mi fa perdere un po allora
segue seguo degli appunti ringrazio ted
perché è veramente è un'occasione
importante per me che devo dire lo
considero un po un momento riepilogativo
della mia vita è il tema
poteva essere controverso diverse
letture ma quello che dà
la nostra organizzazione qui che
ringrazio dell'invito e quella che vi
piace insomma è proprio il momento in
cui nella vita siamo presi per prendere
delle decisioni
e come diceva nell'introduzione
forti o arricchiti dalle dal passato e
parlando verso verso il futuro
allora io faccio due riflessioni spero
di esser breve un contaminuti
minaccioso e quindi spero di starsi la
prima riflessione l'ho chiamata così
attraversare alla storia tentando di non
subirla esso pensato quando la arbia
parlava di quei ragazzi e di quelle
persone che la storia li ha
castigati ma loro possono avere la
capacità di rifarsi perché perché noi
siamo in una realtà storica geografica e
con un bagaglio
predeterminato di capacità negative a
positive
ecco
ma è questa
questa situazione può anche non
segnare il nostro destino
la tentazione sarebbe quella di marcarsi
in una discussione crisi sul
determinismo libero arbitrio
ma evidentemente non c'è incentivo poi
credo che tra di voi ci sia chi che ne
sa più di me di questo ecco allora
vi parlo un po di me e che vale un po di
me perché spesso di essere avete molti
di voi l'età dei miei nipoti e quindi un
nonno è febbre autorizzato un po parlare
di se stesso e anche perché
mi ha colpito una frase di gabry a
viversi a market che dice la vita non è
quella che si è vissuta ma quello che si
ricorda è la si ricorda per raccontarla
ecco allora io sono nato nel
quando quando è scoppiata la seconda
guerra mondiale nell'anno e son vissuto
un po da ragazzo
conoscendola periodo di guerra discorsi
di guerra realtà di guerre anche
immagini e il mio destino cosa poteva
essere una famiglia molto povera
veramente povera chissà cosa poteva
riservarmi la storia e cominciava un
epoca di trasformazioni epocali adesso
la prima dell'azione qui delle
trasformazioni epocali ne presenta delle
altre e quindi le nuove generazioni
dovrà durante le conte far fronte un po
questo
i contadini in quel periodo erano
diciamo così arrivò ad un trattamento
poco poco
uguale quasi e ai tempi dei servi della
gleba perché c'era c'era una situazione
veramente dire trattata e cominciava per
me la grande avventura
della scuola però breve perché a 11 anni
bisognava andare lavorare e non si
poteva studiare e io volevo studiare mi
ha colpito un po questa frase di dear
via prima che un ragazzo voglio studiare
insomma ecco però non era possibile
adesso è grave il fatto che ci sono dei
paesi che non voglio far studiare le
donne proprio per scelta quella volta
non non si può la storia lo permetteva
ai poveri di studiare la scuola mia
stata negata e io ho cominciato a
leggere tutto quello che vi capitava
cominciava l'avventura del lavoro di cui
ho sperimentato e compreso i grandi
valori e anche le ingiustizie perché
non appunto scritto alla prima
prepotenza subita non ho pianto ma con
dieci lire che aveva in tasca sono
andato a contrario il giornale
don milani ancora non si conosceva ma
don milani diceva se l'operaio assa 100
parole il padrone nella 1000
evidentemente l'opera e non potrò mai
riscattarsi ecco io ho cercato di
imparare
questa situazione a tanti altri esempi
anche oggi insomma ci sono delle persone
che colpite dalla disgrazia si si si
schiacciano e si chiudono in casa
altri invece che diventano protagonisti
sul piano sociale addirittura
nell'attività sportiva quindi abbiamo
visto abbiamo visto gli esempi
col passare degli anni così un po perché
leggevo di più sono diventato il punto
di riferimento
per gli altri lavoratori e così il
sindacato e mi ha mandato a firenze alla
scuola sindacale quindi ho cominciato
una scuola diciamo così parallelo al
sistema scolastico a firenze un anno
scolastico per
come devo dire formazione per i quadri
sindacali poi ho fatto tre anni a
ravenna come sempre nel sindacato perché
dovevo fare esperienza e io ho chiamato
quel periodo
stava vivendo un momento di sviluppo
enorme
tra diciamo così
il miglior chiamati clean
in una città storica e si innestava un
procedimento
che io anche anche un po
selvaggio diciamo sono tornato a san
marino
avevo grandi grandi speranze grandi
orizzonti l'ambiente non erano
non coglieva non permetteva grande
grandi iniziative e io sono dato a
rimini dove mi avevano chiamato per fare
è responsabile di zona
in un periodo straordinario perché era
il periodo del dopo il 69 c'è stato un
po il boom
sindacale
diciamo così ed era gli anni della
contestazione che io ho vissuto tutti
dall'interno con una
con un con molto interesse il mondo
cambiava nel sabato 13
il primo relatore il mondo cambia ancora
il so però anche negli anni 70 e ha
avuto grandi grandi grandi modifiche e
del 70 test sono tornato a san marino
ho vinto un congresso e sono stato per
12 anni segretario
di una confederazione qui qui a san
marino
gli anni 70 ei primi anni 80 sono stati
anni in cui
diciamo così con un grande contributo
del sindacato il paese ha fatto
modifiche modifiche enormi e
direi che anche questo per me è stata
come devo dire un po un punto di
riferimento un punto di raggiungimento
della
della vita che avevo sognato insomma da
ragazzo
avevo ancora quel conto aperto con la
scuola e allora
quegli anni abbiamo
diciamo così fissato un diritto il
diritto
allo studio con le 150 ore non so se
qualcuno di voi ricorderà questa grande
conquista è oggi più meno necessario ma
quella volta è stato molto molto
importante e ho fatto
dalla scuola media
maturità l'università
siccome aveva uno slancio anche un
triennio anche un triennio di
giornalismo io penso a questo fatto come
ad una ad un regolamento di conti perché
avevo
tanto ho avuto preoccupazione per questa
per questa
mancanza per questo diritto che mi era
stato negato
il secondo punto
vorrei starci
perché guardo il contaminuti minuziosi
perfetto
il secondo punto lo chiamo il nostro
ruolo nei destini dell'umanità e ci
stiamo anche qui con il tema perché sono
i nostri le nostre decisioni i nostri
i nostri atti che decidono questo
io credo che ognuno dovrebbe avere
dentro di sé lo dico anche a degli amici
politici che conosco dovrebbe avere
dentro di sé il desiderio di lasciare un
segno
dentro il periodo storico che attraverso
e nel ruolo nel ruolo che attraversa
ma della realizzazione di un mondo
migliore
compete a noi quindi ed abbiamo una
grande responsabilità per ogni gesto che
facciamo possiamo fare un pò far fare un
passo avanti all'umanità possiamo anche
far fare dei passi dei passi indietro
pensate voi
le responsabilità soprattutto di quelli
non della mia generazione ma anche di
quelle successive verso verso i giovani
se si decide di fare di indebitare il
paese perché non vogliamo rinunciare non
vogliamo
come devo dire prendere atto dei
problemi che ci possono essere perché
tanto di debiti non li subiamo noi
marche a chi li lasciamo ai nostri
giovani ei nostri ai nostri figli i
nostri nipoti allora il senso di
responsabilità di ognuno di noi dovrebbe
essere quando diamo decisioni guardiamo
anche gli effetti che può avere che può
avere sul futuro e sulle nuove
generazioni
ogni gesto anche piccolo io dico perché
mi ha colpito quel detto era un detto
orientale il batter d'ali di una
farfalla influenza gli eventi in altro
punto della del pianeta l'ha preso
addirittura einstein con la teoria del
caos e io credo che sia vero che
nessun gesto è indifferente per
l'arretramento l'avanzamento del
dell'umanità
ecco si tratta di un modo nuovo di
utilizzare la vita di non cedere ai
valori che propone la storia del team
del momento ma
market che tiene conto che tiene conto
di pensare al futuro e pensare a quello
che verrà dopo
cito qui una frase di arturo paoli non
so chi lo conosca ma è un ponte o rogo e
un profeta dall'america latina dice
bisogna avere coscienza che la vita è
breve
non per aver paura della morte ma per
spenderla bene per cose che valgono oggi
qui e ora ecco quindi
la connessione col tema di questo
incontro
compete tutti noi ecco perché passi
avanti piccoli o grandi
che siano per l'asian lasciano il segno
e la prospettiva per un mondo dove regni
la giustizia
qui sarà che sarà che io ho fatto il
sindacalista e quindi sono un po
condizionato da da questa storia ma una
storia affascinante perché i lavori i
lavoratori
perché sono andate avanti si sono
riscattate perché avevano dei sogni
avevano delle speranze annotato per
queste speranze
io
ci terrei per questo
un inno dei lavoratori
l'internazionale anche privatele vedere
adesso qualcuno magari avrà dei
pregiudizi ma date le vedere ma a me
piace
l'inno delle mondine non non
scandalizzatevi l'inno delle mondine
perché
scrivo sto cercando il raccoglie
materiale per scrivere qualcosa sulle
scatologia delle mondine perché le
mondine avevano delle speranze avere
naturalmente è stato meglio che abbiamo
trovato di sistemi di lavoro meno meno
meno duri però le onde mondine cantavano
lotteremo per il lavoro per la pace il
pane e la libertà e creeremo un mondo
nuovo di giustizia e di nuova umanità
questo è un po la speranza che
la speranza che
può portare avanti il mondo e concludo
adesso non sono stato molto brillante
perché si vede che col foglio in mano
sono meno però
insomma credo di aver detto
concludo
vi prego di non prenderlo come ripeto
come un predicozzo un'esortazione ma
come la testimonianza che è possibile
essere coerenti e trasferire nella vita
quello che si dice è quello che si pensa
perché molte volte
purtroppo se si andasse con quello che
tanta gente dice il mondo andrebbe
meglio poi
nei fatti il discorso non si concretizza
perché il fare a diventa diverso
quando negli anni 80 ho visto che i
lavoratori non ero più gli emarginati
della società perché avevano ormai
condizioni raggiunte
di grafie io finalmente con mia moglie
perché fino agli anni 80
non abbiamo fatto cose diverse ma
finalmente assieme abbiamo
girato lo sguardo sulle nuove
emarginazioni che produce la società e
per dare la nostra piccola risposta
abbiamo fatto la scelta di aprire la
nostra casa
persone ragazzi e persone che potevano
aver bisogno di una famiglia di di
conoscere una famiglia con la sala papa
giovanni di don oreste benzi che avete
conosciuto abbiamo aperto la nostra casa
un'esperienza fantastica lunga 20 anni
che ora che siamo ormai vecchi e
facciamo bilanci della vita trascorsa
abbiamo chiara la sensazione di aver
speso bene la nostra vita è più piccolo
apporto piccolo sarà piccola sara
presente di noi assieme agli apporti di
tutte le persone di buona volontà nel
mondo nuovo che l'umanità saprà
costruire
nonostante quelli che remano sempre
contro
[Applauso]
[Musica]